hey guys dennis here and i will let you  know that today november 15th uh this is  actually our five year anniversary from  when i launched the website uh i want to  thank everyone who's been watching our  videos especially the ones who who  jumped over from think hero tv to our  new channel think hero pro i know it's  kind of a hassle and a pain in the ass  but we had to do that also we we haven't  been updating the website recently  that's going to change i'm going to  change the website we're no longer doing  like written news or anything but it's  all going to be just videos the videos  from the youtube page and as you have  seen we've been updating the the youtube  channel a lot so also if you have any  questions or comments or you know ideas  of new videos that you want to see  you can email us at thinkheropro  gmail.com  or you can hit us up on twitter at  thinkhero also our facebook page uh  think hero fan so i just wanted to say  thank you and hope to talk to you guys  soon